We will now go through an
example that brings together
all of the concepts that
we have introduced.
We have a stick of length l.
And we break that stick at some
random location, which
corresponds to a random
variable, X.
And we assume that this random
variable is uniform over the
length of the stick.
So its PDF has this
particular shape.
And for the PDF to integrate to
1, the height of this PDF
must be equal to 1 over l.
Then we take the piece of the
stick that we are left with,
which has length X, and we break
it at a random location,
which we call Y. And we assume
that this location Y is
uniformly distributed over the
length of the stick that we
were left with.
What does this assumption
mean?
It means that if the first break
was at some particular
value, x, then the random
variable Y has a conditional
distribution, which is uniform
over the interval from 0 to x.
So the conditional
PDF is uniform.
A conditional PDF, like
any other PDF, must
integrate to 1.
So the height of this
conditional PDF is
equal to 1 over x.
Are X and Y independent?
No.
One way to see it is that if
you change little x, the
conditional PDF of Y would have
been something different.
Whereas if we have independence,
all the
conditional PDFs have to be the
same when you change the
value of little x.
Another way to see it is that
if I tell you that x is 0.5,
this gives you lots of
information about Y. It tells
you that Y has to be less
than or equal to 0.5.
So the value of the random
variable X gives you plenty of
information about the other
random variable.
And so we do not have
independence.
Notice that in this example,
instead of starting with a
full description of the random
variables in terms of a joint
PDF, we use a marginal PDF and
then a conditional PDF to
construct our model.
Of course, with these two pieces
of information, we can
reconstruct the joint PDF using
the multiplication rule.
The marginal is 1 over l.
The conditional is 1 over x.
So the joint is equal
to 1 over lx.
But for which values of x and
y is this the correct
expression?
It is correct only for those
values that are possible.
So 0 has to be less than y,
less than x, less than l.
This is the range of values
that are possible in this
particular experiment.
And we can visualize
those values.
They are those that correspond
to this shaded triangle here.
x and y are less than
or equal to l.
And y has to be less
than or equal to x.
If you try to visualize the
joint PDF, notice that since
it only depends on x not on y,
if you fix a value of x and
you look at the slice of the
joint PDF, the value of the
joint PDF is going to be a
constant on that slice.
On this slice, it's going to be
another constant, actually
a bigger one.
On that slice, an even
bigger constant.
And actually, this constant is
bigger and bigger and goes to
infinity as we approach 0.
Of course, the fact that the
slice is constant is just a
reflection of the fact that
the conditional PDF is
constant over the range of
values that the random
variable can take.
Let us now continue with
some calculations.
Let us find the marginal PDF
of Y. How do we do it?
Since we have in our hands the
joint PDF, we can find the
marginal by integrating
the joint.
And in our case, the joint
is equal to 1 over lx.
And we integrate over all x's.
Now, what is the range
of the integration?
If we fix a certain value of y,
the joint PDF is actually 0
in this region and
in that region.
So we should only integrate over
x's that correspond to
this interval.
What is that interval?
It's the interval
that ends at l.
And because this is a line
of slope 1, this value
here is also y.
So we integrate over
an interval where x
ranges from y to l.
In fact, this is just the range
of x's that are possible
for a given value of y.
x must always be larger
than or equal to y.
Now, the integral of 1 over
x is a logarithm.
And using this fact, we can
evaluate this integral.
And it's 1 over l times the
logarithm of l over y.
For what y's is this a
correct expression?
Well, it makes sense only for
those y's that are possible in
this experiment.
And that's the range
from 0 to l.
When y is equal to l, we have
the logarithm of 1, which is
equal to 0.
So the value of the
PDF is 0 here.
As y decreases, this ratio
increases and goes to infinity.
So the log of that also
blows up to infinity.
And we get a shape of this form,
where the function that
we're dealing with goes to
infinity as we approach 0.
Is this a problem having a PDF
that blows up to infinity?
Not really.
As long as the area under this
PDF is equal to 1, it's still
a legitimate PDF.
And blowing up to infinity
is not an issue.
Let us now calculate the
expected value of Y. One way
of doing this is by using the
definition of the expectation.
It's the integral of y times the
density of y, which is 1
over l times the log
of l over y.
And the range of integration
has to be those values for
which we have a non-zero
density.
So we integrate from 0 to l,
which are the possible values
of the random variable Y.
This is an integral
that's pretty messy.
One can actually integrate it
using integration by parts.
But the calculation
is a bit tedious.
So let us look for
an alternative
and more clever approach.
The idea is to divide
and conquer.
We're going to use the total
expectation theorem, where
we're going to condition on X.
The total expectation theorem
tells us that the expected value
of Y is the integral
over all possible values of the
random variable X, which
is from 0 to l.
The density of X, which is 1
over l, times the conditional
expectation of Y given that X
is equal to some little x.
And we integrate over all x's.
Why is this simpler?
When we condition on X taking
a specific value, Y has a
uniform distribution
between 0 and x.
And therefore, this conditional
expectation is the
expectation of a uniform,
which is 1/2 the
range of that uniform.
So we obtain the integral
from 0 to l.
1 over l times x over 2, dx.
And finally, that's an
integral that we
can evaluate easily.
Or we can think even
in a simpler way.
This expression here is
the density of x.
This is x itself.
So the integral of this times x
gives us the expected value
of X. And there's only
a factor of 1/2
that's left out there.
So we obtain 1/2 the expected
value of X. But now, X itself
is uniform on an interval
that has length l.
And therefore, the expected
value of x is l over 2.
And so we get the final answer,
which is 1/2 times l
over 2, which is l over four.
This answer makes
intuitive sense.
If we break a stick once, the
expected value or what we're
left with is half of what
we started with.
But if we break it once more,
then we expect it on the
average to be cut by a
factor again of 1/2.
And so we expect to be left with
a stick that has length
1/4 of what we started with.
So this example is a
particularly nice one, because
we used all of the concepts
that we have introduced--
marginal PDFs, joint PDFs,
conditional PDFs, and the
relations between them, as
well as expectations,
calculations of expectations,
and conditional expectations,
as well as the total probability
theorem.